yeah so like we're talking about sexual
energy like this yeah like like like
[ __ ] i'm saying women fall in love
through sex men fall in love through
quality time and loyalty i must be a man
then
i want to just go back to that how what
do you consider a long-term relationship
um so my first was six years old
how old are you i'm 28. 28. you're gone
uh my last one's gonna be three years
now
three years okay and then i had like a
one-year one
so you had three long-term relationships
and you and you said that you you had
sex and you took it away because you
because it wasn't about no it was one of
those things where before i slept with
them that connection was kind of built
first like i had to trust that person
and know that um it's not just going to
be physical there's going to be
something more there right that's what
that's what i thought you meant but i'm
saying that's for you
a man i would want to have sex with you
the moment i see you like it's like it's
not i don't i want to build a connection
and i want to get to know her
the more you make me wait the less i
probably want to um
that's a bit harsh to say
the the longer you make me wait the more
i want to be spiteful
yeah
yeah i want to be spanish
i want to be spiteful because you gave
it to that guy for in on the one night
stand he wasn't he wasn't crap to you
yeah but me you saw me coming along and
you thought you know what
you know what i'm saying
yeah
like okay i'm gonna be proper this time
i'm gonna i'm gonna keep it close i'm
gonna be proper and he's thinking wait
hold on a minute like
michael got it on day one like you
trying to make me wait four months yeah
all right wait until four months is done
and i've pre and i've pressed you
now we'll see when i've got my post not
clarity if i want to stay firstly that's
assuming
so i've also spoken to a lot of guys who
say that when they sleep with somebody
straight away they tend to lose a little
bit of respect for them it depends and
then they no longer really look at them
as a long-term partner because they
thought okay this was really easy so how
many other individuals is she sleeping
i think the question is is it genuine
because the thing is like what he's
referring to is a girl that gives and i
don't i don't know you maybe you've
never had a one night stand that's fine
but i'm saying well he's referring what
he's referring to is girls that give it
up on the first night for some guys and
then make another guy wait and so it's
kind of like to him well i had to put
all this investment where the other guy
just got it for free so it's really
frustrating to men because they feel
like you're not really attracted to them
because you gave it to the other guy
isn't it a compliment to the man though
exactly
it shows that the woman is taking you
seriously perhaps no i think i think
that's like a woman's point of view
please wait a few months until i feel
like sleeping with you it's a compliment
but that's the assumption i'm making you
wait because i like myself yeah i think
women have a fear if they genuinely like
a guy of
them being rejected okay so you're
saying the reason why you make me wait
is because if you think you give it to
me early i'm not going to respect you as
much as if you made me wait potentially
but then you disrespected me by giving
someone else no chance to wait why are
you doing your business comparing
yourself
because we're men we're we're very
territorial we're very competitive we're
very compe i don't want to i don't want
to have
intercourse with a girl that that's
well i don't want to be taking a woman
seriously when she's had um intercourse
with my friends yes see men can't undo
their biology yeah and and the thing is
um men are but they're predispositioned
to be repulsed by a woman that sleeps
around so and the reason is because
historically they had to ensure
paternity so if they were wiping
basically like wiping a hoe back in the
day they could be raising a kid that's
not theirs and even though we have birth
control nowadays you can't undo their
hard wiring so and the data supports it
because women that
have sex with one person and that's
their husband have an 80 chance of being
in a happy marriage and if they have
sleep with more than five people that
drops down to 20 after 10 years
wow but is that not contradictory to
what he just said about if you make
somebody wait then they kind of become
spiteful and but then you're saying
no it depends how you make me no but i'm
saying like it depends if it's genuine
it's did the girl did the girl sleep
with 20 dudes and then make him way or
is she a virgin and making him wait
because she's a virgin like there's two
very different ways to go about it but
when you kind of start dating somebody
you don't necessarily discuss your sex
life with that individual anyway so like
for example how would you know that i've
slept with x y and z i would not get to
know you and i would know how because
okay you know woman's intuition you know
that feeling you get when it's like no
this guy is cheating a man has an
intuition as well he could smell the
hole
you could smell it he could be like nah
just like not
she'll be like i've never done this
before and then right back
flank she could have just watched the
porn to get herself ready
you don't believe it
i mean your your woman intuition isn't
always correct but no the majority of
the time at some point it's on point so
you know i might not every girl i would
second guess i'll be like you know what
i'm going with my intuition not every
time i'll be right but majority of the
times i'm right because there's certain
signals that girls give off
when they tend to be more persecute um
what signals are there no no no no no no
that's what the men called no no no
there's no maintenance
that's what the father
you're saying um signals women give up
about being more promiscuous yeah i'm
very open sexually um i grew up in
a family that was very like sex wasn't a
taboo subject my daughters i speak very
openly with freely with them about sex
and
i had slept with one person from i was
50 until i was 33 in a whole 18-year
relationship
and i was very open sexually but
i find that
some people will look at that as being
oh that you can openly talk about sex
and orgasms and things that they would
think
that's
she must be promiscuous because she can
talk about sex or she she loves what you
said no no i'm not i didn't say it no no
no i said science i'm saying to you
that's i think sometimes the signs might
be misconstrued because absolutely i
think men think that women being open
talking about sex
and
talking about orgasms being very like
sometimes
sometimes men are wrong you're right
like sometimes they don't guess
correctly but i just like the point is
that when men
realize that a girl has been ran through
it repulses them
and they can't help it it's their
biology yeah the same way women want a
guy that's taller than us because we
wanted a guy to protect us that's our
biology but we're in control of body
count men aren't in control of height
yeah i agree
so
like you don't think okay
if your friend has done something yeah
that she wasn't supposed to do uh-huh
can't you just feel it on her like she's
just done something like i like
i you can't put your finger on it yeah
but it's something about your friend
like no you did something you did
something with him and it's like that
intuition that men has when you've been
around enough women to know like this
that there's just like triggers that's
like wait hold on i've seen i've seen
that before okay i'll i'll stop and i
wouldn't immediately um give her the um
i'll give her the benefit of the doubt
and be like okay that was just one sign
and then i see another one it's like oh
oh it's starting to compile now yeah so
when it's compiled now of certain things
that you look out for as a man to know
like a promiscuous woman is not
necessarily the same as a woman that's
abstaining no i i hear what you're
saying because i mean i've met men and i
thought wow
like you you as you said about the
protection i'm very like i'm a man's man
and i've initially thought yeah and then
saw wow
you're not about that life
and i've i do not have the same way
you're saying you can smell a hoe it's
like i can smell a [ __ ]
yeah like
so yeah i get what you're saying like
it's like you could tell like this guy's
faking it he's not really he's not
really really bad
he ain't alpha like yeah he's pretending
like you don't he does he says the right
things yeah but you could just tell it
the bucket no no definitely so that's
the intuition that men are that men can
see in girls and they're like wait hold
on i'm not going to let her know that i
know i'm going to sleep with her first
and then i was just going to ghost or
i'm going to go with a friend or i'm
going to
do i'm just going to um keep on sleep
with her and not give her a relationship
i'm going
to say he would do things other than
make you his wifey to be walking on the
road with you holding hands so everyone
else could see yeah but then if we make
you wait that's an issue as well
it depends who
if you're all right if you've had um
intercourse with someone in the scene
london is a very small place and a big
place at the same time please be
guaranteed that i know at least three
people that you've you've you've
not necessarily slept with but you was
talking to or you was doing things with
if i could tell by the caliber of guy
that you're around what you're saying
and i'm speaking to these guys because
men talk to each other on a you like man
just needs to give another guide a
little wink like
that's you mighty like you know says hey
girls they do it as well yeah we do i'm
saying girls give girls the look like
men do things to let men know eggs don't
go there that's me so just to understand
you're either
the girl that you're going to end up
with has either got to be a saint that's
not slept around and makes you wait
or
if she's got an open sex life unless she
has sex with you straight away she's not
good enough either so what is your no no
i'm
ideology
you're trying to put me in the corner
with without genuinely i'm trying to
understand what it is
i'll make you understand
if you are accustomed to sleeping around
yeah and then you find that one guy that
you're really interested in want to make
him think that i'm a good girl and he's
going to like me i'm going to put my
best foot forward and i'm going to make
him wait and do that he already knows no
no no no i already know what you're on
i've already seen the whole play already
i'm not coming to you ma'am you have an
only fans yeah like you know what i'm
trying to say like i've don't think the
first time i'm coming to you is the
first time i've seen you i've already
got the play oh what's what's maria
saying okay all right all right what
would you not do the thing yeah what
mine was that okay well she's on that
yeah all right say no more sam okay let
me let me hold him maria when i see
maria hi maria you're right you're so
beautiful i love you you don't say god's
angel i love you so much look in the
eyes and talk to you in your ears and
whisper and stuff i'll make you think
i'm like you know what i'm saying like
i'm i'm not being genuine but i'm being
genuine if you get what i'm saying i'm
interested but i'm not going to take you
as seriously as i could you could tell
me from a guy's point of view you want
to be the guy that she breaks rules for
yeah like she made everyone else wait
but she slept with you right away and
you're not the guy she's doing it for is
it nice but then on the other hand
is it say that again isn't it nice to do
the opposite as well though like maybe
she slept around a load of guys but she
wants to take it slow with you because
she really loves her
i want to hear from every guy in this
room is that nice
no
i didn't hear what you said she said if
you do the opposite she sleeps with
everyone and takes it slow with you i
want to hear from everyone in the room
material surely i don't get that what do
you mean
isn't it nice to have rules broken for
you
so if a woman sleeps around a lot yeah
yeah then she meets you and she's like
right i want to i want to get him to be
my husband i want to take things slow
yeah
isn't that a sign to you that she really
likes you and is invested so what if she
likes me i don't care if she really
likes me it's not me
she's not gonna be one thing to do with
me liking you i've i've already
disqualified you because i know what
you're like but you know what i think
so you say that you would your friend
would give you the lowdown yeah she's at
home and then you're gonna buckle and
say yeah why go on maria um let's go out
on a date but really all you want to do
is smash no not date
who's that date wow well it's like
whether you want whether it's a smash
date or a dinner day or whatever you
want to smash but then you're not being
transparent so then because you're not
telling that you just want to smash no
but a lot of girls like he doesn't take
them out on a date he doesn't treat them
like a girlfriend and then they sleep
together and then she's mad
because he doesn't wife her but he never
was he never they weren't dating
intentionally ever anyway i never told
her i want to be your wife i want you to
be my wife i didn't say that i'm just
chilling with you and we happen to have
intercourse i'm not taking it seriously